how will I get sin is the Institute of
arson ideas unique festival combining
days full of talks and debates in
philosophy politics arts and science
with evenings full of music and dance
get your tickets for the world's largest
music and philosophy festival but how do
I get in as a guy who wrote a book on
irregular verbs come to lay a book on
enlightenment recent science humanism
progress sprang from a obsession with
human nature I argued in a book called
the blank slate
another philosophical issue that there
is such a thing as human nature that it
is shaped by evolution implemented in
the wiring of the brain by our and I
examined why that very concept of human
nature as opposed to the idea that we
are blank slates that are simply written
on by society and culture why is the
blank slate so appealing emotionally
morley and I argue that there were one
of the reasons that people resist the
idea that we are involve preachers that
we have a human nature is that it seems
to many people to - any hope for social
improvement the fear is that if there's
such thing as human nature you can just
dismiss attempts to reduce violence to
reduce greed to reduce discrimination by
saying oh it's just human nature you'll
never get rid of war because he would
serve generally more like that leads
people to say well there better not be
any human nature or else we're going to
these are the strokes for all eternity
one of the points I made in the book in
the blank slate just in passing was
that's a non sequitur
the fact that human nature exists
doesn't mean we have to behave in the
same way in perpetuity because human
nature is complex it does have some
nasty bits there is such a thing as lust
and
selfishness revenge and dominance but we
also are equipped by evolution with
self-control with empathy with reasons
with moral norms and it's a question of
how the balance between those different
parts of human nature plays out in a
given time and place that determines how
we actually behave and I know that
almost in passing that I can't really be
a debate as to whether human nature
dooms us to a constant level of strife
because we just know looking at history
slavery was abolished Soviet empire
collapsed with violence and I know that
the rate of homicide had gone down
and your ever since the Middle Ages well
when I repeated these observations in a
blog post I started to get
correspondence from scholars in various
disciplines all over the world saying oh
you could have added even more examples
of how violence declined you know that
rates of death and war have come down
over the last 70 years did you know that
violence against women is diced did you
know that every European country saw a
drastic drop
interpersonal violence I realized
there's a big story there that very few
people are aware of that on many scales
of time and magnitude violence has been
in decline over the course of history
so not being a professional historian or
political scientist I realized that
still I was privy to all of these
sources of data from different
disciplines that deserve to be put in
one place so I wrote a book called the
batteries
but as a psychologist this decline of
violence also posed the challenge to me
of explaining how it happened why were
so people from people so violent in the
past how do they manage to attain this
violence to psychological questions once
I started to be open to data on the
course of human history then I started
to come across other datasets showing
that it wasn't just in the case of
violence that we've made human life
better but we also live longer
we are better educated we more of us
live in democracies we have a more
leisure time in measure after measure if
you remove yourself from the headlines
and look at the data and you see vast
human improvement poverty has been
decimated worldwide and I thought this
needed a book as well extending the
lesson about improvement in peacefulness
to improvement in other measures of
human flourishing and once again a
challenge of explaining it were our
human nature hasn't changed in the last
couple of centuries how did we manage to
improve human life there I think ideas
matter and one of the key ideas that
more sets of ideas that I have led to
human improvement were the ideas that we
associate with the Enlightenment the use
of Reason to figure out the world as
opposed to dogma or faith or Authority
the attempt to understand the physical
world by applying reason to it what we
call science the idea of humanism that
what counts morally is suffering and
flourishing of sentient creatures
including humans as a and that those
ideas when implemented were what eked
out the progress that you could see in
the graphs
how do you respond to criticisms to your
book that talked about the fact that
life has only improved for certain
groups of people and it's false that the
whole point of book his life is improved
across the world global poverty has
declined from 90% of the world's
population to 10% of the world's
population not proportionate people
living in democracies has risen from 1%
to about 2/3 entire regions of the world
that were at war are now in peace
literacy is improved not just in rich
countries but in poor countries the
whole point of the book is that this is
not a development that's confined to the
to the rich or to the West so anyone
making that criticism has not opened the
book and yet we have populism and Trump
and neo-fascism rising does that have
anything to do with the fact that we're
also embracing enlightenment values at
or is that something that we just that
is totally outside this realm there's
all ever since the Enlightenment and
unfolded there have been counter
Enlightenment philosophies that have
opposed it and the Enlightenment by no
means has won the day in all periods and
that right now is the latest wave of
pushback against Enlightenment ideas the
movements of populism and fascism light
and nationalism downplay the individual
they prioritize the glory of the nation
or the tribe or the race they downplay a
reason saying oh that's just what
experts believe and instead go with the
sentiment of the of the people conceived
of as a as a tribe or a unitary polity
rather than the worked out
procedures and laws of democracy they
seek to empower a charismatic leader who
embodies the soul of the people directly
so this is the latest pushback it's not
the first
I certainly hope it would be less
successful in previous I'm really
interested in which you in the way you
created a kind of dichotomy between the
celebration of the individual that the
Enlightenment has embraced and then this
narrative of the nation or the tribe or
the collective but at the same time you
did mention empathy and I suppose care
for other sentient human sentient beings
and so is there a tension between the
individual and the collective
and is individual is not linked to the
Enlightenment at all there are all of
these categories and I'm not sure how
how you place them in in this scheme of
the Enlightenment as you see it humans
are social animals and none of us could
exist without a couple a family a
community our happiness our well-being
very much depends on being part of a
successful community one way of
cooperation and harmony prevail over
competition at the same time it's the
individual who who feels pain who
suffers and flourishes if you cut a
group of people in half and put half on
the one side and half on the other it's
very different from cutting a person in
half in terms of damage in terms of pain
in terms of suffering so are our moral
concerns should be with the individual
the entity that actually suffers or
flourishes while recognizing that the
individual part of the source of
suffering of and flourishing of an
individual depends on the community that
they belong to and we as a social
species we can only live in peace and
harmony if we have the equivalent of a
social contract if we have institutions
like a democratic government like
regulated markets like Institutes of
Education and charity
and a court system and rule of law that
that are bigger than any individual but
the happiness of the individual depends
on those systems working so would you
say then that an Enlightenment kind of
feeling of you know fellowship for
instance or like feeling related to
other people and goes along the lines of
cosmopolitanism rather than along the
lines of kind of embracing local
identity or how does that tension
between the local and the global get an
important enlightenment theme was
cosmopolitanism that each one of us is a
citizen of the world but because we're
all human we share common interests this
is not to deny the the fact that we
belong to multiple groups we're humans
first and foremost but we're also
Londoners or Britons or Jews or
Catholics or fans of one team versus and
other or users of one brand of camera
equipment or another people form various
teams tribes clans which is fine if they
are not set in violent competition
against one another and if no one of
these group memberships completely
dominates the person's identity and
would you say that that is the problem
at the
and that there are groups that are
dominating those where others apart
there's a big problem when people think
that their group can prosper only at the
expense of other groups when people
forget that the benefit of joining the
group is that it enhances the lives of
the individuals making it out people
think that it's good to sacrifice
hundreds of thousands of young men as
cannon fodder in Wars of national glory
that would be an extreme case of
neglecting the rights of the individual
in favor of the glory of the group and I
think that's why I think of groups is as
well by tacit social contracts not as if
we actually laid out a social contract
that never happened but still the way
the group should function is as
something that gives to individuals what
we obviously could not get if we were
ISIL is just wandering around on our own
final questions so um it seems like all
of your latest books have flowed one
from another has enlightenment now
inspired you to write another another
book and if so well I tend actually to I
in writing books I tend to alternate
between books that are closer to my own
specialty of cognitive science books on
language books on mind and books on
bigger themes that are that connect to
human nature like the history of
violence like enlightenment values my
next book will combine them it's a
tentative title is don't go there common
knowledge and the science of civility
hypocrisy outrage and taboo on how we
get along or and sometimes don't buy
either knowing that everyone else knows
something that we all know or by keeping
it to ourselves and I'm not allowing you
to be out there is common knowledge and
in this governs a lot of our social
emotions that governs our conventions of
civility and politeness versus moral
outrage and lobbying and shaming and
that there's an interesting
explanation in terms of our psychology
in terms of game theory and it too will
draw both on philosophy philosophy of
convention and common knowledge on
psychology psychology of norms and
taboos and politeness and mentalizing
trying to figure out what's going on in
someone else's head
and current events in history how has
your experience of puzzle Vegas and
being so far so far so good once with
the bathroom or too long the highlights
are just meeting so many people
interested in in deep issues and willing
to engage in conversation about ideas
that matter among the public or among
these speakers as well both but but
first most notably opened up public the
fact that there can be a cultural event
that attracts people who were interested
in ideas is I I think a hopeful sign a
lovely event get your tickets for the
world's largest music and philosophy
festival how the light gets in aaaggghhh